hey guys it's Pete and we had another
cool episode of mr. robot last week this
will be my season 2 episode 3 review and
I just want to throw it out there right
from the beginning that our new
characters dom and rey pretty much won
the day this video was delayed because
some personal stuff I had to get done so
let's get right into it
we start out with a flashback to Coney
Island where we see how Romero got
involved with that society in the first
place
Mobley gets together with him and he
tells us the long strange history of how
he got a hold of the arcade in the first
place we find out that Romero did some
time in the past for hacking stuff and
that his Sully gave him the key because
he thought the place was haunted as they
talked Romero isn't interested in
helping mowgli at first but he talks him
into at least meeting elliott we get a
nice aerial shot with another cool song
in the background and we see what looks
like the bandage that Elliott had
wrapped around his head and he and he's
thinking about panic let me get a
continuation of Elliott's conversation
with Tyrell
not yet where I'm supposed to be but
soon very soon
I don't think that's a good idea using
census
don't tell me you're having second
thoughts
don't worry about you
so we don't find out much here except
that it's too dangerous to talk about
anything Eliot wants to know in a heated
exchange with mr. robot we have an
interesting part where Eliot is talking
to us and mr. robot us why he is asking
us about whether the phone call is real
or not we had that shot of his bandage
where it looks like it is stuck to the
wall with blood this could be an
indication that it is a delusion since
the real bandage shouldn't have blood on
it since they didn't really have a
bullet wound in his head I'm interested
to know what you guys think about this
I'm not sure at this point if the call
is real or not initially I thought it
was a dream because of the way the scene
was cut in the last episode but now it's
a little more unclear or at least at the
timeline isn't as certain as it was what
is clear is that Eliot says that he
wants you know what what he always
wanted and that's for the panic to stop
and they doesn't want to let mr. robot
to make him a prisoner of his own
paranoia
Eliot also finds out about Gideon's
death from a TV news report his mother
is watching in the other room and we
find out that his killer surrendered at
the scene right after it happened from
there we meet Romero's mother mother as
Mobley comes over because he hadn't
heard from him she sends him downstairs
where he finds Romero dead in the lab
it's a pretty big shock and we we see
this like a smashed cell phone next to
his body it looks like he has been shot
in the head and there's a little bit of
slider on the body this looks like the
lotion that he showed mr. robot and it
could be a clue as to how the killer got
close enough to take him out we visit
Rey at home and we listen in on a
conversation that he's having with his
wife we get a shot of a dialysis machine
in the background and at first I
expected that she would be the one who
was hooked up to it
Rae mentioned his wife and that he has
breakfast with her when he first met
Elliot so we assumed that maybe she is
bedridden and this is like his normal
routine he you know he takes care of her
he talks to her as he's feeding her
breakfast the conversation is mostly
small talk but we learned that there is
a limit imposed on withdrawals of $50 a
day like due to the hack sort of like
what happened whenever the financial
crisis happened in Greece he then
reveals that the only way he is getting
through this which is indicating the
dialysis is by having breakfast with her
so we learned that he is on the dialysis
machine and he is talking to Anne
chair later on in the episode we find
out that his wife actually is dead
Eliot is back at the basketball court
and Leon shows up to pass him something
in a handshake when he first sits down
Leon lectures him about being careful
with the dosage and then mr. robot shows
up to ask if he is getting back on
morphine Eliot takes off but stops to
tell him that it's time for him to get
rid of mr. robot and then he proceeds to
take a bunch of the pills one after the
other he lets us know that it's adderall
not morphine and if you're not familiar
with adderall it's an ADHD medication
that's pretty much the opposite of
morphine it's a it's an amphetamine
which is basically speed you know a
pharmaceutical II produced version of
crystal methamphetamine when a computer
gets hit with a kernel panic there's
only so much you can do an internal
fatal error is hard to recover from I
mean listen to that internal fatal error
sounds pretty [ __ ] bad you ask me
but OD'ing on adderall was finding my
way of controlling him
do you have a moment mr. Alderson is
this a feeling Gideon so there we get an
idea of where the title of this episode
comes from and a little homage to
Heisenberg from Breaking Bad give me a
look at state of mind I think it's a
little that's a cool little Easter Egg
the show has been pretty obvious about
the nods it makes to other cultural
things like you know the gotfox masks
from anonymous and so on so it works
without being too cheesy I mean I don't
know the the masks are actually a little
borderline but I guess the point is that
when it points these out in an obvious
way it's better than just co-opting the
ideas and trying to pass them off as its
own I do know that when I saw the guy
from behind you know for a second I
thought there was actually going to be
like a Walter White cameo so that was
cool Eliot get snatched up by some men
in suits that are riding around on
suburban which for good reason he fears
are the FBI they they hood him and then
they drive off and we cut to the subway
we get some references to how screwed up
everything in the world is post the 5/9
hack and it is notable that pretty much
every transition scene there is has some
indication of how the system is breaking
down we see Mobley on the train and
Darlene comes to sit down next to him
check out the Ecore ads behind them you
know it's just a constant reminder that
things are basically going nuts Darlene
is is their typical cynical self and not
pisses Mobley off because she basically
said that you know they warned her and
Elliott warned them that you know Romero
was a liability I get the doctor Darlene
is trying to stick to this idealistic
point of view of following through with
what F society started but her character
is taking like a pretty unlikable turn
and I'm starting to wonder if it's just
a smokescreen
you know maybe trying to cast suspicion
on her as being the person who was
pulling the strings behind those deaths
but you know because I I really don't
think that she had anything to do with
it
Elliott arrives at a parking garage with
his abductors and we recognized the
scene from you know the preseason
trailer they zip tie him to a chair and
then they start to mix up mix up some
concrete and a red wheelbarrow at this
point you start to realize that the
abduction isn't real as they you know
they're basically pouring concrete down
his throat which would most likely kill
him it's worth mentioning here that the
wheelbarrow was what he had written on
his journal and you know that concrete
would definitely wreak some havoc on the
system's ability to work properly you
know a system like a human body for
instance we see Eliot in his room puking
on the floor and mr. robot is now
wearing the Walter White hat as Elliot
is losing all the pills in the puke mr.
robot tells him that he owns him
this leads Elliot to dig through the
vomit to find and retake each of the
pills the scene ends with Elliot keeping
them down and saying that he won't be
owned and he looks pretty satisfied with
his decision to go forward with Angela
is it working at Ecore and we see her
getting called in to Phillip prices
office he tells her that he's sorry
about Gideon and that she made a mistake
when she set up the interview with the
news she thinks before leaving the room
and decides to argue her case for him to
follow the course that she'd laid out it
should be noted I guess that she also
thanked him for the you know the
condolences and that it had been
bothering her about getting his death he
tells her to sit down they have a
conversation about a restaurant he knows
about and he ends up inviting her to
dinner and then he goes on to agree that
she was right and that he should do the
interview with Bri what was it
Blumberg rather than Fox News like he
mentioned on her way out she stops to
look at a photo in his office wall they
have an exchange about how you know he
noticed that she looks at it every time
she leaves and that maybe she finds it
as fascinating as he does and he lays
out that you know he thinks it's
fascinating that how a man can change
the whole world with a bullet in the
right place if you're wondering what the
drawing is it's a rendering of the
assassination of Archduke Franz
Ferdinand and his wife Sophie this is
the event that led to the start of World
War one the assassination happened in
Syria Sarajevo when they were there and
it was a 19 year old Serbian national
national assume he shot about the close
range and they both died within like an
hour after it happened or something like
that
we see that FBI agent DOM is lonely too
she is in bed watching a TV show on her
computer and it's like a you know a
relationship program or something like
that
she talks to her Amazon echo and Alexa
tells her it's 4:00 a.m. she talks to
Alexa several times during the episode
and there's a sort of parallel between
Ray Elliot and Dom in that they all talk
primarily to people that aren't real or
at least
not real in the sense that they exist in
the present time I think this is
interesting because in Ray's case it
makes him empathetic and I wonder if
with Dom it'll do the same since she's a
law enforcement officer on the case on
like related to the hack instead of
empathy it might give her an advantage
in actually catching Elliot at the same
time either way she gets ready and looks
tired she goes to the crime scene at
Romero's and we get the idea that the
agents on the scene aren't the most
competent in contrast she appears that
be knowledgeable and has an idea that
the computer will be rigged to destroy
the data as the forensic techs is
getting it ready to transport she asked
his superior if he checked the ports and
at the same time the computer catches
fire there's a quick shot of a document
with the that has like FBI agents names
on it that Romero had printed out and
Dom notices her own name on it Darlene
and Mobley visit Trenton at home and the
three talk about Romero's murder
Darlene assures them that the dark army
don't know who they are and that they
don't know who Romero was Mobley and
Trenton are fearful and it becomes clear
that they don't really trust Darlene or
Elliott Mobley says he is going to take
off to Arizona and Darlene tells them
that they show that she will actually go
talk to Elliott and get back in touch
with them when she knows more after she
leaves Mobley and Trenton talked some
more and he emphasizes that they are the
only ones who talked the dark army you
know being Elliott and Darlene and they
might just be covering their tracks he
also points out that Elliott as mr.
robot had pulled a gun on a Romero in
the past we see very threatening a guy
we've never seen before he's doing it in
a really calm and collected manner
they're talking about Bitcoin and the
and the new guy says he is an
experienced enough to do the necessary
work to secure a website that they were
I guess that you know they owned
together or have mutual interest in it
isn't clear if this is before Elliott
health Rey or not but it seems like this
is the problem he told him about in the
last episode it's noticeable that we're
talking to is that they're talking with
his family right in the room and the guy
has already been roughed up before they
talk we don't know exactly what Rey is
into but we get the idea he's going to
need help to get things figured out Rey
does mention that the guy he the guys
that he works with are dangerous and
that he is like sort of a Rheem positive
reinforcement guy you know making a
contrast there we see him in a band
afterwards with a
who was obviously the muscle and the one
who beat up the guy that he was talking
to and Marie explains that you know he
can beat him up again but it's not gonna
make him know something that he doesn't
know Eliot tells us he's a man up for
three days and that mr. robot is gone he
is clearly wacked out and we get a
frantic scene of him popping pills and
rolling around like completely eked out
he says it is more aware which is
obvious and Leon is concerned he's you
know they have a little conversation and
Leon isn't feeling it it's a cool scene
that kind of shows us how Elliot is
willing to go without sleep and you know
becoming something he isn't really just
to get rid of this conflict that's
inside of his head you know he's
basically running from his problems at
the end of the montage he looks into the
camera and says that you're not buying
this to us the viewer and then we get
this glitched out scene where you know
the inevitable basically happens it was
feeling good for a few days it really
was wasn't it but this is the fifth day
not sleeping
I think if isn't that a funny word
there is again
the overwhelming fear building the
burrowing nesting
backwards this isn't good
that's
err
from which my system cannot safely
Colonel panic so the crash starts and
Elliott realizes he can put the panic
off but he can't make it go away
completely Angela's getting ready for
her dinner with price and we hear her
doing these personal positive
affirmations in the mirror she's getting
ready again her nervousness seems to
dissipate as she tells herself that she
is likable and that she is attractive he
arrives at the restaurant to discover
their two other men there though and
that throws our off quite a bit they're
introduced as executives in E Corp and
we learned that at restaurants like this
nowadays you have to pay up front in
order to order your meal it's all from
the fall out of the hack obviously this
part of the scene ends with the toast
and we see that Angela is wondering what
price is up to we get we then go to DOM
and she's in bed and she's basically
masturbating after doing some dirty talk
on IRC if you didn't catch the handle of
the person she's talking to it's happy
Harry hard-on which is like a nod back
to Christian Slater's character in the
movie pump up the volume which was 90s
ish movie it was it was okay it's kind
of funny if you go back and watch it now
Tom isn't able to finish and so if she
asked Alexa when does the world end the
device gives her a very real and frank
answer and that prompts Tom to get out
of bed and she goes over to the state
that she has in her closet where it
looks like she keeps her phone she looks
at the photos of the leaked FBI agent
details and you know the one she took
from Romero's place and we go back to
Elliot he is in his church group looking
at his notebook where he has scribbled
down the error details from the kernel
panic screen we saw earlier he says that
he is about to crash and mr. robot will
come back and he mentions that he
couldn't escape Gideon's death that his
dam of guilt is finally cracking we hear
a story from one of the other group
members that's pretty disturbing about
him beating up a man for being different
you know being a foreigner he doesn't
really make a flat out just to kick
justification for what he did but he
basically says it happened for a reason
and the you know the religious little
slant the group leader kind of gives him
comforts him by saying that Jesus loves
them Elliot kind of laughs under
espresso she turns to him and asked if
he would like to share and we get a
really memorable
that shows that the if you know the
euphoric effects of his five-day speed
binge are all the gun addicts afraid to
believe the truth that there's no order
there's no power that all religions are
just metastasizing mindworms meant to
divide us so it's easier to rule us by
the charlatans that want to run us boys
of their poorly-written sci-fi franchise
I don't listen to my imaginary friend
why the [ __ ] should I listen to yours
after the anti-religion anti God speech
that everyone in the room seems to be
uncomfortable with Eliot realizes that
he was talking out loud and decides to
get up to leave on the way out he throws
his journal in the trash we go back to
the dinner with price and he excuses the
other two guys that are eating with him
and Angela he personalizes them D'Angela
by towing her some of the good things
that they've done you know normal
everyday human things and he then tells
her that they were in the room with
Colby when the decision was made that
led to the death of her mother he he
provides her with some evidence that his
staff has put together of some inside
trading insider trading that you know
they were involved with and thus gives
her a chance to ruin their lives he
leaves it open so she has to make a
decision to act and she tells him that
she doesn't trust whatever it is that
he's doing you're panicking right now I
understand it's a big decision you're
making because these men their lives
will be destroyed but the minute you
remove emotion from this
you'll do just fine it's a really
powerful scene as he invades her
personal space and gets into her head at
the exact same time
and it makes you wonder about his true
intentions the hook of his dialogue is
that she'll do just fine once she takes
emotion out of the equation he's
basically giving her a taste of playing
God and yielding much more power than
she would have otherwise in any
situation so really for the first time
I'm kind of interested in what Angela
story's gonna be like going forward we
find Elliot back at the diner looking
like he's about to crash ray walks in
and returns his journal and says he you
know that the chaplain at the church was
an old friend of his and he you know he
heard what happened over there he tells
Elliot that his wife died over five
years ago and how he talks to her out
loud each morning during breakfast
Elliot asked him why he's telling him
that and morenae explains that he thinks
that him and Elliot have more in common
than Elliot does we find out the dawn
was on her way back to mrs. Romero's and
we get a pretty funny you know back and
forth that's also revealing and how
thorough Dom is at her job she basically
gets her way in to the apartment by
offering to help out mrs. Romero roll
her joints because you know the police
had taken them and Dom though she has
arthritis so she probably can't do it
herself and she offers to help they end
up talking and this leads to her mrs.
Verma asked him for a glass of water and
Dom ends up finding the flyer for the
end of the world party you know because
it's wrapped up in it inside the box
where it's been packed away Elliot's now
with rain in his office and it becomes
clear that he read the journal and knows
about what Elliot's struggling with it
puts him in a place of being vulnerable
which he obviously doesn't feel
comfortable with but at the same time he
kind of realizes that there isn't much
he can do about it either ray tells him
that control isn't real and he discusses
his theory that life isn't about getting
back up it's actually about the fall
it's about stumbling in the right
direction we hear Eliot think about it
and we see mr. robot reappear when what
ray gets up from the chair as Elliot
models over the idea that you know we
might just be getting to the right
answers by asking the wrong questions we
see Dom again arriving in Coney Island
as he finishes his thoughts the episode
ends with her standing outside of the
arcade realizing that it says
F society right on the sign so I think
this was a really strong episode and I
think that the new characters and their
the loneliness parallels that they have
with Eliot are moving things in a good
direction we didn't get any Johanna in
this episode but DOM and Rea have
presented us with two very different
obviously flesh you know flawed
characters which bring up a lot of
questions and things to wonder about as
the season progresses sort of like right
as Gideon and Romero slip out of the
story
it doesn't really lose anything in the
way of mystery as far as what the big
picture will be is far you know for
Elliot and mr. robot it'll be
interesting to see how these three
characters come together and how Darlene
and Angela's stories will affect Elliot
when they actually come back into
contact Rey seems like a vehicle for
some level of healing and at the very
least you know coming to terms with the
idea of you know hey I'm Elliot and I
have a dual personality what the hell do
I do about it of course you know price
is always awesome and you know the
wellick story even though it's gone you
know we're right for the moment I'm sure
it's not gonna be off the radar for very
long I'm really curious as to what you
guys think so let me know in the
comments like do you think that DOM was
gonna get close enough to Elliot where
there's gonna be an actual face-off and
if so do you think that she's up to the
task of unveiling just how the 5/9 hack
went down when we have Gideon in romera
in their position to shoulder the blame
so how do you think Darlene's gonna
proceed with things once she gets back
in contact with her brother I hope you
enjoyed the review I'm really excited
for the next episode again I apologize
this video took so long and you know I
just had some stuff going on Danna last
week and this time you know I'm gonna
try to get it out exactly you know right
after the fact on Thursday you know as
soon as I can
looking forward to the comments and
going down the rabbit hole with what you
guys think is you know shaping up for
the you were were whatever a third of
the way through the season at this point
and so what do you think's where do you
think things are headed please like the
video and subscribe to my channel talk
to you soon